[Music]
we're going to go to philadelphia
pennsylvania with becky hey becky how
are you
hi i'm very good how are you good what's
going on
so my question is how do you create a
budget after betrayal i just found out
six weeks ago that my husband has been
cheating on me
um he is repentant and is we are both
seeing counselors and trying to work
through this
and last night we tried to do our budget
we have been following the ramsey plan
for a few years
um
we are completely debt-free including
our house
so
the thing we're not on an agreement on
is do we stop our investing
and dip into our emergency fund
or do we
keep investing and use the money that we
sold that we made from selling the
business
yeah we we got a lot going on here becky
what business and what money do we need
to dip into for anything cause i thought
y'all were debt-free help us understand
what specifically you're talking about
um my husband sold his business dude
yeah and they got a new job
because yeah he would have more
accountability there and he would not be
working by himself so we sold our
personal business so the money that we
need from that we could use to help pay
for counseling and also we took a pay
cut so
to
help us through the next few months
or years i guess it takes three to five
years to be
clean from all this okay okay well first
of all i just want to say i'm really
sorry that happened i'm really sorry you
went through that and that's really
really emotional
to take on
in addition with trying to deal with the
tactical so um yeah you know rachel and
i will definitely help you process the
tactical of the money um but i i'm just
so um so glad you guys are in counseling
because that that is just gonna be so
great to have a professional in your
corner to help you process
that
as you're going through that yeah and
becky you know we
will say a lot on um
on this show that when something
kind of tragic happens um just to pause
that you're good you know just
take a deep breath and um you know a lot
of times when there's grief involved and
there's a love and there will be grief
with this um situation when you're six
weeks out it's still really new
uh
yeah this wasn't six months ago or six
years ago i mean this this just came out
last month right so um yeah so i i would
say you know you guys are you're in a on
the financial side you're in good shape
right you you guys don't have debt yeah
you've taken a pay cut your lifestyle
make a little different but i would i
wouldn't make any
i know you guys sold the business to get
him in a position with accountability
and all of that and i think that's a
smart move on just you guys and how
you're going to function going forward
um but i wouldn't do anything rash i
wouldn't make any big decisions right
now because there still is a lot of pain
and so i think for you all
just um the budget's probably gonna look
different uh because of the pay cut and
so i think re-looking at
not trying to keep the same lifestyle
and so when you asked about stop
investing and all of that i would do
what i can to
to
and again it's going to be hard because
it's going to look different your
lifestyle will look different but try to
live within that new income is going to
be
the best thing going forward versus
taking money out of an emergency fund or
stopping investing
to keep the same lifestyle that you guys
were living six months ago it's just
you're in a different you're in a
different spot so i would do what i can
to
live off of that new income
that he has create a budget around that
uh and even if you guys can't for some
reason
make bills on that but you should be
able what what is it becky i don't know
if she said that what what is the income
the new income
the new income
um
i'm trying to think
anywhere from
it the 80
around 80
50 80 something like that
so it's
his first he just got his first paycheck
it was 2200 for two weeks so whatever
that would be annually
okay honey something
funny i didn't do the math but yeah so
if you're debt free i'm just curious
i'm not great at you know mental math on
the spot but if you're completely
debt-free
why do you feel like that you couldn't
live on that that you'd have to dip into
savings or stop retiring stop your um
investing for that
why wouldn't you be able to live on that
is it your house um
no
the one thing so
because we had inconsistent income
before we try to do our budget a month
before so like what he gets from october
we'll use for the november
um budget so he's working ahead
and
um
yeah the thing is we had we tried to do
a month budget off of a two-week
paycheck and i was like okay we need to
move money over and he was not okay with
that he's more like he like to pinch his
pennies and
no i'm we don't need to we have you know
so much saved up in our retirements or
in our business accounts like we don't
have to pinch our pennies right now
he's been very controlling
which
makes me angry
yeah what
i hear that in your voice becky
is that something you're working through
with your counselor because that that's
a strong word
i thought that can be
um
yeah
it just came up so
um
i haven't been
i've been trying to
but it's painful do you ever do you ever
talk to your counselor just you
without him present
yes i do okay
are you honest with your counselor about
what's going on yes yeah
i guess this financial thing never came
up before because this was our first
budget meeting
so yeah yeah and
well i was just really triggered i guess
you could say yeah for sure
for sure um do you think as of now and
it's six weeks after i know um that you
found out but are you got you're you're
working to stay together and you think
that that do you see hope in that yeah
yeah we we both want that okay um okay
and i i am seeing a change in him so
yeah
he wants to change okay so that's one
thing i'm like i even thought about like
creating the budget myself instead of
because of his
decisions he made
like he was spending money on unreported
side jobs so yeah i mean like using cash
in that way for
yeah i was like i can't trust him with
the finances right now so that would be
my thing like yeah which is legitimate
becky yeah yeah that's that's legitimate
um
yep when there's um deceit and lying
uh that's where that goes so um
and do you work outside the home i i do
not understand her mom right now okay
um
okay let me just again let me answer a
tactical question for you just so when
we get off the phone you have something
um to think about so when you're saying
that you're you guys have never budgeted
before just know that it's it is always
tough okay so you guys running into
these kind of conversations and all that
affair or not is very normal so just
hear that give yourself a lot of grace
so the first few months of this is going
to be difficult
um
and number two the the two-week paycheck
is difficult too to budget because what
you're saying is the money that happened
from the last paycheck is what you're
using for this and all that so so in an
ideal world and especially since you
guys are debt free to have enough money
in the checking account that can help
you pay for a month's worth of bills
on a tactical level is going to help so
if you need to pull that month from your
emergency fund to have to be able to
physically pay the bills and then as the
paycheck comes in for the 15th you're
going to use that 15th and then the 30th
paycheck for the next month does that
make sense
yes you're going to still budget every
dollar but the actual cash flow can go
so for him pinching the pennies and all
that you guys just need money in your
checking account
to help get this budget flowing so you
can do that
um i i'm all for that
and and for you guys again yeah getting
a budget together i think is is for sure
in a perfect world but no you there's a
lot of pain becky so i just want you to
have a lot of grace for yourself and if
you guys can't get to this
for another two or three or four months
like
it's okay
your marriage is important right now and
yes money is a big component of that and
i want that to get together but i want
you guys to heal from your marriage
which is going to help heal
from the trust with the money as well
and bring that up with your counselor
bring the budget conversations as an
example of the conflict or control to
your counselor and help them work
through that and dig to the deeper
issues they're they're great at that
that's what they do